i mean if you mention it should we just
talk about games then like what games
you've been playing all right what do
you
what have you played recently have you
been playing anime games no i never play
anime games
you never i've never played anymore okay
what am i what
what constitutes an anime game though
that's the thing um if the characters go
yeah
that's like every game yeah yeah you
could say last of us as an enemy gaming
that's it
they have a cute app
i don't know like how many games do you
guys play because i
found that i just have zero times to
play a lot of games nowadays
now that the quarantine is over here
right yeah it's a gamer
verified gamer girl as a pro gamer
as a gamer i don't know i mean i feel
like uh
it's probably the thing that got cut the
most when i became an adult like
out of everything that i do watching
films doing anything else like
gaming got cut down the most for me
because in universities because that's
what you used to do right
i used to do gaming for like 12 hours a
day no problem jesus
yeah it was easy i love that [ __ ] i used
to play like legalizing defense of the
game actually for me like i played
when persona 5 first came out i
definitely started playing or then 12
hours a day on that i know like for me
the reason i don't play many games
anymore is because
when i get into a game like get into
yeah
yeah i'm like one of those guys who just
can't go
like i either have eight hour gaming
sessions or i just don't game at all
there's like there's like no in between
yeah yeah um like especially if it's
like an rpg or a story driven game like
i remember when persona
when i last played persona 5 it was just
like my
just just block out my week nothing is
happening this week but me
playing persona 5. yeah which is why i
haven't played royal yet
i mean i played persona 5 persona 5
royal and persona 5 scramble
and i think in total that took maybe
like
5 600 hours out of my life this man
finds time where time shouldn't exist
i mean that's what i like about animal
crossing right because i'm still playing
that
to this day and i've put in maybe like
three four hundred hours into that game
but that's the thing right it's like
unlike most gaming sessions where it's
like zero hours or eight hours
yeah animal crossing is one of those
games where you could play for half an
hour and then you can just
drop yeah that's fair enough yeah which
is what i like right it's just like a
little thing to just kind of do on the
sideline as someone who plays
league of legends i feel like even if it
is a 40 minute game session
pro gamer here that [ __ ] felt like eight
hours
that mental battle that it took to play
a game of league of legends took eight
hours
yeah but i [ __ ] used to love playing
league of legends man i'm so addicted
are there any like actual like games
based off anime that you guys like
or what do you mean like by anime games
i don't mean like
games with anime looking characters like
i'm not talking about like a xenoblade
or like a dragon quest eleven kind of
has there
ever been a good anime spin off i'm sure
that no i didn't it's just i can't
really think of any right now
well i mean like you know all the attack
on titan game on steam i was like yo i'm
so hype
i get 10 minutes into the game like
probably dragon ball fighters that's
that's do you like the fighting games
i mean i i'm i'm not very much of a
fight game enthusiast but i mean i had
fun playing it and i think it was a
pretty good i enjoyed um
what was the the latest like naruto
fighting game like i'm not a huge fan of
naruto arena
the latest one on that on steam like i
think someone gifted that to me
and i just gave it a go but i was like
you know i'm not that much of an
advocate for like fighting games i'm not
that good at fighting games and i'm not
much of a fan of the naruto franchise
but i gave it a go that game's genuinely
fun
right i mean you have um what's the
what's the pokemon fighting game oh
pokken
i like pockets yeah it's good i like
that if you like pokken it's it's
similar to that just with naruto
no one ever wants to play pokemon
pokemon it's so fun it's good though
because
i do you know you bring your switch to a
party right you're like i've got mario
party
i've got mario kart i've got all these
amazing multiplayer games right yeah the
last thing anyone wants to play is
pokken but if people give it a chance
it's actually fun yeah i don't think
it's a great game
but it's really funny it's fun it's
really really fun yeah it's just like a
brain dead
fighting game it's really easy it dumped
it down a lot but i think it needed to
be because i suck at fighting games well
here's here's a question for you guys
and have you ever
watched an anime and thought this would
be a really cool game
because i i can think of one off the top
sword
for that song be a good game though i've
played the sword online games they all
suck
wait there's one in the arcade yeah and
i'm not just saying that because i don't
like start online like genuinely
they all suck i just had a huge epiphany
the jojo battle uh the jojo fortnight
the georgia fortnight game the jojo
fortnight yeah there's a
in japan they have an arcade game and
it's a battle royale of jojo and you go
around mario
and and all you do is like try and
[ __ ] punch each other to death it's
so fun that game's fun
it's kind of bad it's kind of a bad game
it kind of sucks but it's good